so the ethical aspect about the leaks
themselves you know some people have
made decisions we're not talking about
it that type of thing and then the
second about what was the most
surprising what did you extrapolate the
most from the data of the leagues floor
your yeah so so the ethical aspect I I
have to quote my my boy ACA here where
he says you don't get to pick and choose
when you start
to become ethical you've had a very very
long uh Legacy of in on it and all of a
sudden we're supposed to adopt this
attitude why like we've had very similar
with Capcom we had personal details
leaked it was a malicious hack and all
the like loads of stuff happened and
then you had you know the likes of Greg
Miller and stuff like jokingly laughing
at the fact that there will be punitive
measures taken against them as they've
got the leaked footage there on the
screen so I'm like come on bro